hey what's up guys mkbhd here with a  quick test video in 720p hd at 27 frames  per second on the motorola droid x as  you can see it's looking pretty good  also i'm taking this video as a quick  opportunity while i have a microphone to  let you guys know that uh the reason my  videos for the past four weeks and for  the upcoming two weeks until august 7th  i actually don't have narration because  i don't have my microphone and i'm away  from home so if you're looking forward  to uh forward future mkbhd videos i'll  be trying to have the most awesome  possible music for those videos in the  background so until then stay tuned for  future videos and i hope this was a good  preview of the camera quality on the  droid x thanks for watching peace